Let's try to write down an algorithm that systematizes how we solve it. And
we're going to write this as pseudocode. That means we're not worrying about the
details of how to write exactly correct Python. We're trying to get the idea
down and see if it makes sense. So let's think about how we solve the problem as
a human again. Here's how we start it. We looked at our start date, which was
January 24. And we counted the number of days remaining in January. We do that
by just counting up. If we started earlier we might not want to have counted
every day. So we can subtract the total number of days in January from the day
we started. So that will be our starting point. And we're going to keep the
results in a variable called days and we'll start by initializing days into the
number of days in the current month minus the day that we're starting on. So, for
the example, that was 31, for the number of days in January, minus 24, which, I
believe is 7. And once we've done that, well, we finished month1, so we should
increase the value of month1 by 1. So now we were at February and now we started
going through the months, until we got to the month we are on. So we went
through each month until we got up to the month we were looking for, which was
June. So that's sort of like a while loop. We're doing something over and over
again until we get to the stopping condition. So we can write that as
pseudocode. We're going to keep going while the current month is less than the
target month. We're going to add the number of days in the current month. And
we're going to increase the current month by 1. Now, we're not quite done we
still need to account for the day in the month that we arrived at. And there we
just add that day so if it was day one of June then we would add one, since we
didn't actually get in to June. Now, we're going to add 29 since the 29th was
our target day. We haven't yet accounted for years, for this example it was
okay. But, for other cases, we're going to need to account for years, so let's
think about how to do that. We can do it similarly to how we accounted for
month. Well, we're not up to the same year. We're going to add the number of
days in that year.